The joe rogan experience
every fucking show I do.
People will yell out to every show,
every show,
but fucking if people
are yelling shit out.
That's,
and that was,
I never even really did.
I have talked about it
on stage a few times,
but I don't know.
Yeah,
I heard the audio.
You talked about the time that you and
I did it where I thought you were going
to die,
but every fucking show,
like it was like my closing bit for years.
It was,
uh,
there was one of the weirdest psychedelic
situations for the folks at home.
Uh,
Doug and I were doing the man show
and it was like in the death throes,
right?
It wasn't right here we was,
we had to spend all night writing,
trying to save the fucking thing.
We knew it was a disaster.
We got fucked.
I mean,
look,
we,
we both appreciate the fact that everybody
was disappointed by how that show
came out,
but no one was more
disappointed than we were.
The whole thing was a mess.
And when we don't need
to get into details,
but uh,
if you,
unless you want to no,
no,
no it's fine.
It's over.
It was terrible show but there
was some great shit in it.
I defy anybody to watch the uh,
my midget sketch.
You do?
What is it?
Another man's mentioned it cause your,
your sketch a defy anybody to watch
that and tell me that's not hilarious.
Where are you trying to steal
the old midget from the man show?
Bring him over to the
new head shot with us.
I mean it was a,
it was the wrong thing at the
time because our show is not,
the learning experience was priceless
cause that was my first real television
and just knowing how they fuck it up.
We could have,
we could have done
something on the Internet,
we've could have done something like
Internet style where there was no input
whatsoever and we could have
had a great fucking time.
Right.
And when,
when they came to me with the idea,
the idea was we're going to have nudity,
we'll blur it out immediately.
I'm thinking Joey d is going to be naked.
The beginning of every fucking show
is just telling someone about that.
And then,
and then I said,
oh,
and what about swears?
And they said you could
bleep it out and bleep out,
talk about whatever you want.
They go,
it's a good thing if we get sued,
this is what stone
Stanley guys telling me.
If we get sued,
it's a good thing.
I'm like,
we aren't gonna Fuck Shit Up.
I'm just can't wait for
abortion monologues and chaos.
And when we got in there,
it was a totally different story.
As soon as we got in and the audience
wouldn't have liked it any better.
No,
they would've still hated it,
but we wouldn't have had to fuck,
we would've had two bags on our heads.
We would have had to rebuild
and make a new audience.
You know there,
there's one point in time with John
Stewart didn't use to host the daily show.
Right.
You know,
people forgot there was that
other guy and it really,
we shouldn't have called it demand show.
We should have said,
we are really into the idea of taking
over that time slot or that idea that
doing this new [inaudible] had told
us to pound sand probably it'll fuck
ourselves.
We might know.
Yeah,
they were.
They were convinced that that name was
going to sell everything and that was
going to be the big push
and there's name brand.
I'm like,
it's said,
but it's not the same Sheldon at
the same guys and not here anymore.
None of the writers he here,
what the fuck he documented
can you were doing fear,
fear factor 14 hours a
day that I got so greedy.
I was like,
I am going to have two shows at the same
time and I was just thinking it's just
doesn't up that money.
I could never work again.
Never work in again.
I'm never working again.
If that was a dumb I
down terrible ideation.
Never do more than one television.
If you didn't have to work,
would you stop?
No,
not stop doing.
Stand up and maybe you know,
I liked doing the UFC too,
man.
It's nothing I do right now is
really work between standup.
I mean I can or I can regulate how many
times a year I'd go out and the UFC.
I was like,
I look forward to it.
It's fun.
So it's like,
what am I going to do this weekend?
I could stay at home and I can go to the
movies or I fly to Indianapolis and I
watched some dudes beat the fuck out of
each other from five feet away and I get
paid for it.
I get to call it does.
It never feels like work.
Google might be skynet.
Yup.
Well whatever,
you know it's,
it's,
it's inevitable.
I mean everybody wants it again.
Make me hard.
Ladies and gentlemen is signed.
That keeps falling for the folks that
are on iTunes that don't get to see this.
When Doug and I were on the Mancho,
I know we complained,
but this is,
this is pure evidence.
That was,
that was the best story.
Hard.
We,
we had a game show that we created
called make me hard and it was,
it was one of the best things we
did when it actually turned out.
And the reason why it was one of
the best things we ever did is uh,
because it was tranny caucus trainee cock.
Yeah.
But we,
we the,
the show's called make me hard and then
when we actually made the show and when
we,
you know,
talk to the comedy
central people in every,
they didn't like hard,
hard was too dangerous.
They wanted to be make me
stiff and we were like,
what the fuck is the
difference is the most,
this was right before we're about to
tape to art department has to rush.
We,
they allowed fucking full open tranny
cock open tranny cock cause we're going to
blur it out.
Simulated fellatio on
a banana by a midget.
This is what happened.
All the language.
This is,
this was the Gig,
there was a kid,
they would strap him to a chair and
they would put it this harness back up
because a lot of people
probably don't remember,
make me laugh,
was a game show where people tried not
to laugh while comics try to make other
guys would get in their
face and say silly things.
So make me hard.
We set them up.
Where would they have this box on their
package and we would decide when it lit
up indicating that they had an erection.
So we had,
so they had to try to not get
a boner during these sexual,
yeah,
so of course it would go off,
midgets would eat bananas.
It would go off and we had
this really hot tranny.
She was so hot that Eddie Bravo and I
were at the comedy store one night and we
were coming down and we got to park
at the high end at the comedy store.
Parking lot was full and we were coming
down the ramp and she was coming up at
eight he's going,
God damn,
that bitch is on.
But this chick coming up right now.
Whoa.
She's so pretty.
I go,
that's a dude.
I've seen his dick.
That's how hot and like
her name is vanity.
And she's totally believable.
If you ever think that you
can't get tricked by a trainee,
there's no way.
I wouldn't know.
You wouldn't care.
She,
yeah,
she blew a dude.
We know and just did
it because Weiss twice.
Yeah.
Once on this set.
And then once,
and then she called him after she was at
her hotel and he went back the next day
or something.
He's so hot.
We're calling them her.
She,
her name was vanity and
you can find her like,
I think it's vanity.
Ts you Google.
I've founded a short of people who'd,
who'd blame him?
So anyway,
the,
we,
the guys,
you know,
strapped to this table and she
climbs all over him and he's,
he licked her tits.
Right?
I can't remember.
Poor fucking guy.
We tortured this guy's memory forever.
So He's,
he's like,
everyone's going,
yeah.
Yeah.
People cheering.
And then she pulls out this
trainee deck that looks like,
like a poison monkey Dick.
That's what it look like.
It looks sick.
He'd been hitting so many female hormones.
It was like an old man in a wheelchair.
That's what it takes.
And she pulled it out and it was black.
It was black as it functional
or is it just a bunch of snow?
No,
it's done.
It's all done.
I mean,
it's just hanging on shell,
but it feels good when you suck it still.
Right.
You know?
Even a soft dick feels
good if you suck it right.
But I don't think,
I don't think there's any,
unless she pops viagara maybe she can pop
the Agora and I still have a hard day.
Okay.
You're a fucking human being.